I gotta if it's okay uh read to you a
few of your own words you open oh boy
the book Mother of God with the passage
that I think beautifully Paints the
scene
before he died Santiago Duran told me a
secret it was late at night in a palm
thatched Hut on a bank of the temple
Potter river deep in the southwestern
corner of the Amazon basin
besides the mud oven two wild boar heads
sizzling sizzled in a cradle of Embers
they're protruding tusks curling and
static Agony as they cooked
the smell of burning
sucropia wood and singed flesh-filled
air
woven basket containing monkey skulls
hung from the rafters Where Stars speak
through the gaps in the thatching a pair
of chickens huddled in the corner
conversing Softly
we sat facing each other on sturdy
benches across the table hewn from a
single cross section of some massive
tree now nearly consumed by termites the
song of a million insects and frogs
filled the night
Santiago's cigarette trembled in the
Aged fingers as he leaned close over the
candlelight to describe a place hidden
in the jungle that line
the songs of a million insects and frogs
filled the night for some reason hit me
um what's it like sitting there
conversing among so many living
creatures all around you every night in
the jungle you live in constant
awareness of that out there in the
Darkness
are literally millions of heartbeats
around you and so like
we exist in this in this you know
domesticated paved world most of the
time but when you go out there past the
roads and the and the telephone poles
and the hospitals and you make it out
into Earth just wild Earth and there's
no there's no there's not like this is a
national park there's no rescue
helicopter waiting to come get you you
are out there
and you're surrounded at Night by I mean
there are snakes and jaguars and frogs
and insects and all this stuff just
crawling through the swamps and through
the trees and through the branches and
we put on headlamps and go out into the
night and just absolutely fall to our
knees with Wonder of the things that we
see it's it's absolutely incredible and
most of it doesn't make sounds like the
insects do the insects do the frogs do
you have some of the night birds making
sounds but a lot of it everything has
evolved to be silent invisible
I mean everything there is in the on on
the list like like I there's another
lion and Mother of God where I said like
you know like life is just like a
temporary moment of stasis and like the
churning recycling Death March that is
the Amazon like it's um it's been called
the greatest natural Battlefield on
Earth I mean if any in any square acre
there's more stuff eating other things
than anywhere else and and you go
through a swamp in the Amazon
and there's like this tarantulas
floating on the water there's frogs in
the trees there's there's
tadpoles hanging from leaves waiting to
drop into the water this fish waiting to
eat them there's birds in the tree you
literally are surrounded by so many
things that your brain can't process it
it's it's just overwhelming
life
churning Death March
some of the creatures are waiting and
some of them are being a bit more
proactive about it
what do you make of that
churning Death March that the amount of
murder that's happening all around you
at all scales what is that you know we
uh we dramatize Wars and the millions of
people that were lost in World War II uh
some of them tortured some of them dying
uh with a gun in hand some of them
civilians but it's just millions of
people what about the billions and
billions and billions of organisms that
are just being murdered all around you
is that
um do you does that change your view of
nature of life here it I've always kind
of wondered like that like when you see
like a you know wildebeest taken down by
lions and and eaten from behind while
it's alive and it makes you question God
you know you go how could how could how
could they let this happen
um in the Amazon
I find personally that these natural
processes make up
almost a religion that it reminds you
how temporary we are that you know the
the bot flies that are trying to get
into your skin and the mosquitoes that
are trying to suck your blood and the
you know when that when you sweat you
see you see the you literally can like
hold out your arm and watch the
condensation come off of your skin and
rise up into the canopy and join the
clouds and Rain back down in the
afternoon and and then you drink the
river and start it all over again and
it's like it's flowing through you so
uh the Amazon reminds me that that
there's a lot that we don't understand
and so when it comes to that
overwhelming and Collective murder as
Werner Herzog put it
um it's just part of the show it's part
of the freak Show of the Amazonian night
I see you I you in at certain moments
able to feel one with a mosquito that's
trying to kill you slowly and one with
the mosquito is a stretch is it always
the enemy what I mean is like you're
part of the machine there right yeah and
it's like Fair Play It's like fair play
so like we have bullet ants and like you
know you get you get nailed by a bullet
ant you just go yeah well well done well
today's today's over I'm going back to
bed and I'm taking a pile of Tylenol and
you know do you think in that sense
when you're out there are you a part of
nature or you're separate from Nature's
Man a part of nature or separate I think
that's what's so refreshing about it is
that out there you truly are
and so whether we're bringing
researchers or film Crews or or whether
we're just out there ourselves on an
expedition
um you truly are part of Nature and so
one of the things that that my team and
I started doing when I became friends
with these guys you know this is a
family of indigenous people from the
community of infierno and they took me
in and
as we got close they started saying you
know you can come with us on our like
annual hunting trip and I went okay
and it's four guys in a boat and you
don't want to get your clothes wet so
we're all in like our boxers in a canoe
with a motor going out past the places
that have names and you're out in the
middle of the Jungle and the thing is
like when you're when your motor breaks
you are so quickly reminded of
the inerrant truths like the things that
nobody can argue with and we live in
such a human world where everything is
debatable religion and politics and
perspectives on everything and then you
get down to this point where it's like
if we don't
figure something out the river is going
to rise and take the boat that's the
truth and ain't nobody gonna like argue
with that and it's like to me there's a
beauty in that truth because then all of
us are united there and that and that
truth against like the natural facts
around us
and so to me I that's that's a state
where I I feel very very at home and the
Amazon is more efficient than most
places on Earth at swallowing you up oh
God yeah okay
[Laughter]